dan campbell has gotten the job with the
detroit lions with a
six-year hazard pay deal a six year
we're not dysfunctional
and will prove it by signing you for six
years here he is yesterday from his
introductory press conference explaining
what the new look lions
are going to be doing on the football
field
so this team's going to be built on
we're going to kick you in the teeth
all right and when you punch his back
we're going to smile at you and when you
knock us down
we're going to get up and on the way up
we're going to bite a kneecap off
all right and we're going to stand up
and then it's going to take two more
shots to knock us down
all right and on the way up we're going
to take your other kneecap and we're
going to get up and then it's going to
take three shots to get us down and when
we do we're going to take another honk
out of you before
before long where they're going to be
the last one standing all right that's
going to be the mentality
kind of sounds like the lyrics to a boy
named sue but i digress
let me let me peter i want your thoughts
on this i've been cooking up a hot take
all week long since it's since it's suit
and tie season for nfl head coaches
and and my first thought when i see dan
campbell dressed like that is are you
going to a funeral
maybe he is but i don't understand
why these guys do their introductory
press conferences
in suits and ties i appreciate the
entertainment value
such as when ben mcadoo shows up in the
david byrne giant suit
but i don't understand you never see
these guys in suits
and i i we saw some press conference
footage earlier this week from dan
campbell when he was the interim coach
in miami and he's in his he's in his
coaching gear
and he's much more loose and comfortable
and it works well i mean this is the
first impression
i don't know why there's this weird
convention of slapping these guys in
suits and ties am i am i onto something
or am i is this just as they would say
on seinfeld cookie talk
it's kooky talk i don't care nobody
cares i don't care i care
i'm not nobody i'm somebody but why
why do you care why do you care who
cares because it's so weird because it's
weird
why why what's the purpose of it we've
just always done it it was like that
when i got here
it just makes the guy look stiff and
stilted and not himself
and this is your opportunity what are
you trying to do you're trying to sell
season tickets you're trying to get
excited you're trying to get people
going
you don't have to show up like you're
you're rolling into the board boardroom
for the annual shareholders meaning show
up like that
let me see the let me see that physique
sun's out guns out baby
i want to see what my coach is going to
look like on game day not when it what
he looks like when he
when he shows up uh you know to bury
someone that's just my own personal
i thought you'd be with me on this one
every once in a while okay but mike
mike mike mike mike mike don't you
really want to see press conferences
with uncomfortable suits on
and people like adam gase going like
this
[Laughter]
i i i understand there's entertainment
value
and there will never be another ben
mcadoo giant suit i hope there will be
i'm saying if it's my team i'm going to
take a step back and i'm going to say
this really i don't know that this
really serves a purpose who's going to
who's going to look down on us because
dan campbell shows up in the latest
version of whatever nike is creating
that they want people to go
buy i'd rather do that have him wear
something you can go buy hey i want to
buy the hoodie that dan campbell had a
brand new nike hoodie for the new lions
head coach that's what i'm it's just
it's just let's see what the guy is
going to look like on game day not what
he looks like when he's showing up
uh uh to for his job as a high school
assistant principal that
i i i okay so listen i do like the
entertainment
that comes from uncomfortable coaches in
suits
on another great lions press conference
coach story you remember the name daryl
rogers he was the coach of the detroit
lions in the 80s they were awful
and at the end of the second year when
they were awful whatever 2 and 14
3 and 13 whatever it was the owner
william clay ford
came to the press and he said came to a
press room one day and he said
i've decided to bring daryl rogers back
for a third year
and daryl rogers that day at the press
conference
the writers said hey the the owner just
said he's bringing you back for a third
year
and daryl rogers first line was what's a
guy have to do to get fired around here
so but i mean i was thinking the lions
have had a lot of great moments with
their coaches over the years with the
press
but man you're gonna have to go a long
way
to beat biting both kneecaps off
and that's how we're going to beat you i
mean aaron rodgers is going to have to
go go out and get kneecap
insurance this offseason yeah yeah you
know i i don't have the rulebook in
front of me but i have a feeling that
that biting kneecaps off is frowned upon
that's unnecessary roughness
is that it could be a violation that
would be a violation of one or more
provisions of the official rule book the
actual
application of teeth to the flesh at the
area of the knee and the removal of the
patella
would tend to be the involuntary patella
ectomy if that's even the phrase for it
i don't know that anybody has their
kneecap removed but that would be the
way to do it mike did you
when you were watching that when you
were watching that
were you thinking that how perfect it is
this year that chris spielman was
in the interview process isn't this guy
chris bielman as a coach i mean
that's that's exactly what that was the
first thing i thought of when i saw that
quote yesterday
well that's why i got the job i mean
chris spielman wasn't just in the
interview process he was running the
process barry sanders said that last
week barry sanders was involved barry
sanders has just been like a ghost in
nfl circle since he retired he was
involved in the
coaching search and and this gets back
to one of the things i love
and fascinates me about the nfl you get
these people like sheila fordham who
really don't know what to do so what do
you do you find somebody else to do it
for you
she found chris spielman to do it for
her and
yeah former player who would bite
someone's kneecap
off if he could not that he was dirty
but it was that same kind of passion
that dan campbell is advocating
he's going to be attracted to a guy like
that and that gets back to the enemy
thing
you got to have you got to have people
in the position to make these hires
who will see and be attracted to the
value
that eric b enemy has spielman was
entrusted with
the campbell hire he was attracted to
campbell and
uh whoever is entrusted with the hire in
houston and
on any given day i don't know who the
hell it is uh
will they or won't they be attracted to
the enemy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports